good morning Hank it's Tuesday March 26
2013 also known as spring you know
spring when daisies pied and light looks
blue and lady smocks all silver white
spring thou with dewy locks who look us
down through the clear windows of the
morning spring which is like a woman who
says oh yes I'm here again and your
heart knows I was coming spring when the
hope of man as well flowers among the
morning dews a light exists in spring
Emily Dickinson wrote not present on the
year in any other period where is this
light Emily Dickinson is it down there
with the snow is it up there in the gray
sky of doom because that looks exactly
like the winter white hey when the Yeti
and I first moved Indianapolis we
dropped off the moving van at the u-haul
place and the guy was like welcome to
Indianapolis and I said how long have
you lived here he said about 30 years
and I said well what do you think of it
and after a second he said well you got
to live somewhere I think that follow we
have a lot of people feel about their
hometowns but I've really come to love
Indianapolis even in the spring snow
it's an unpretentious City of hidden
beauty which is by far my favorite kind
of beauty and it's lovely even in winter
but I am ready Hank I am ready for
spring Hank the calendar has made me a
promise that outside has failed to keep
stupid outside always ruining everything
so Mike I don't actually believe that
magical thinking works or anything but I
thought for today's video I would share
my favorite poem about spring in the
hopes that spring will like happen I
also love this poem because it reminds
us that poetry is partly in the business
of getting us to try to pay attention
it's by EE Cummings oh sweet spontaneous
earth how often have the doting fingers
of Puri and philosophers pinched and
poked Vee has the naughty thumb of
science prodded thy beauty how often
have religions taken be upon their
scraggy knees squeezing and buffeting
thee that thou mightest conceive gods
but true to the incomparable couch of
death by rhythmic lover thou answerest
them only with spring you gotta live
somewhere Hank but you also get to live
somewhere so brace yourself my friends
spring is coming Hank I'll see you on
Friday